[Music]
in a recent statement lucasfilm and
disney announced that the obi-wan kenobi
series is about to start shooting
in the process the official cast has now
also been confirmed and so we
finally know we'll be standing in front
of the camera together with ewan
mcgregor
on the one hand there's hayden
christensen who has long been rumored
for the role of anakin skywalker or
darth vader in the disney plus series
but joel edgarton and bonnie please two
actors from star wars episode 2 and 3
are
also returning lamely owen and beru lars
this is particularly interesting because
luke hid out with them for a while and
it's rumored that this specific time
period plays an important role in the
new series
this does make sense as the series is
set 10 years after episode 3 and 9 years
before the action of their first star
wars film
in 1977 and revolves around obi-wan's
exile on the desert planet of tatooine
but besides mcgregor christiansen
edgarton and ps
there are other new additions that many
may not have had on their radar for
instance
there's fast and furious actor sun kang
comedian kumail nanjiani
and newcomer moses ingram who was
convincing in the netflix series
the queen's gambit sadly the concrete
roles for the new cast members are not
yet known and is
quite likely that some of the actors may
only lend their voices to androids or
aliens
deborah joe who has already directed two
episodes of the mandalorian is
responsible for the realization of the
obi-wan kenobi series
other producers behind the camera
include kathleen kennedy michelle raywon
ewan mcgregor and screenwriter joby
harold if production of the six part
series goes well
we are optimistic about release in early
2022
may the force be with them
according to deadline magazine a new top
class actor has been signed up for the
upcoming mcu blockbuster
thor love and thunder the talk is of
gladiator star russell crowe who will be
seen alongside chris hemsworth natalie
portman and christian
bale the 56 year old tough guy is
currently still the subject of
speculation as to exactly what role he
will play initially the australian was
only supposed to make a small but great
guest appearance
however the fact that he has since
posted photos of the set with the cast
and has already been there several times
gives us hope for more yet that's not
the only news because judging by rumors
jeff goldblum will also be part of the
cast naturally this suggests that we can
also look forward to a return of the
grandmaster from thor ragnarok
but this has not been officially
confirmed there's still no information
concerning the plot of the fourth
thor movie all we know so far is that
taika waititi is in charge of directing
and that the marvel movie
is expected to be released on may 6 2022
until now we could only speculate about
the release of black adam
after reporting on the signing of bond
actor pierce brosnan last week
we are pleased to announce further news
about the dc blockbuster today
in the course of a large-scale publicity
campaign the massive billboards of new
york's times square were temporarily
taken over by black adam
on them you could find the title of the
film and surprisingly the official us
release date july 29th
2022 simultaneously johnson's
threatening voice booms out of the
speakers and announces a hierarchy
change
in the dc universe that's quite a
declaration of war against the
superheroes of marvel's competitor
if you happen not to be a times square
at that moment you can watch the epic
show
at the rock's instagram account now
we're looking forward to the movie about
the shazam antagonist even more and are
eagerly awaiting the end of july 2022
a couple of days ago warner brothers
released brand new character posters for
the upcoming
space jam a new legacy starring lebron
james
the sequel to the 1996 original comes as
a mix of live
action and animated film as it did back
then and centers around a legendary
basketball
match between lebron and many looney
tunes characters against an alien team
the 36 year old nba star will be joined
by don cheadles unique martin green as
well as various personalities from the
world of basketball
the family flick is directed by malcolm
d lee we look forward to the release
date of july 16
2021 we have two pieces of news about
the new mortal kombat movie adaption
firstly warner brothers has announced
that the release date will be moved back
to april 23
2021 secondly the game adaption is to
reveal one of the most brutal fights in
film history
more details were revealed by producer
todd gunner after director simon mcquoid
already announced a few days ago
that the blockbuster would be pushing
the envelope in terms of violence
garner went even further as he announced
that there would be at least one fight
that would be among the most vicious
fights he had ever
seen in the movie therefore the audience
can look forward to a fair amount of
action and we are now even more excited
about the release on april 23
2021 in theaters and on hbo max
as lionsgate recently reported the
action comedy the hitman's wives
bodyguard will now be released
earlier than scheduled after the release
date of ryan reynolds film free guy was
moved to august 13
2021 the sequel to the hitman's
bodyguard will now be released on june
16th
2021 in the us this is of course a good
sign above all for fans of the film
series but it also makes us feel
optimistic about other blockbusters this
summer as slowly but surely more and
more film studios are deciding against
further postponements of their projects
and in favor
of an early release moreover a statement
by lionsgate president ron schwartz
what's an interest in the film because
in his opinion
this is exactly the right action comedy
for this summer as well as being a
perfect introduction for all newcomers
to the franchise
whether the sequel will then also
correct the 176 million mark of its 2017
predecessor
remains to be seen as mentioned earlier
the us release date for the hitman's
wife's bodyguard is now set to be on
june 16
2021
[Music]
you